okay but go ahead trt no but it's just
like trt is an example of people wanting
to become faster stronger and or they
say you know go into a cold plunge for
this exact amount of time follow this
exact regimen because this is the thing
that's going to improve your life and
cure disease XYZ it's not true is a cold
plunge good for you
if you like it if you like the challenge
but medically I'm never going to
recommend to my patient ever in my life
as a physician to go do a cold plunge I
like cryotherapy isn't that like yeah
why I'm asking you why yeah I don't know
I don't know why people are recommending
it there's no evidence to say it really
does anything valuable
and it's expensive it's time consuming
most patients do not live in this world
that they can afford to buy a tub throw
ice in it every day like it just it's
not about this is the difference between
people who are excited about information
and are researchers versus someone who's
a clinician and actually sees patience
and the hard time they're having in
their everyday lives and then I want to
come in there and be like oh in my fancy
suit I'm going to tell you to get a cold
plunge and if you do it for three
minutes and not three minutes 13.4
seconds you fail
it's not real there's no evidence it
doesn't exist well without being that
specific about whatever you have to stay
there for three minutes is there any
upside aside from mental challenge that
you feel like you've I haven't seen
anything in the evidence that shows me
that it's very worthwhile
okay the clock remember I do everything
caught like Risk benefit okay ozempic
well let's stay on that to lose weight
to lose five pounds how do you feel
about that
it's not what its intended uses and why
that's dangerous is because when a
medicine is studied by this evil farmer
that we're talking about it's studied in
a certain population people for ozempic
as an example people who have type 2
diabetes who are overweight or have high
blood pressure or some kind of heart
disease it's studied in those people so
when you're taking it as someone who
doesn't have any of these diagnoses and
you take it how do I know that the risks
you're facing are going to be what the
ones that we found in the research when
we didn't test it on people like you
it's the same reason why we suck at
treating women's heart disease because
we never did research on women's heart
disease so when a female patient comes
in and says oh I have a little acid
reflux maybe a little arm pain we
discount it and they're having a heart
attack because our initial research
we're was not done on women it was done
on men who said I have an elephant
sitting on my chest this is how I
describe it and that's how our common
knowledge is of heart disease and
therefore we miss all these heart
attacks in women same thing we have to
know who the research was done on to
decide whether or not ozempic is safe
for losing five pounds in an average
healthy person we don't know
foreign
[Music]